hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar real-world utility a Siegel
calprotectin testing presented by dr. KP
park associate professor and co-director
Stanford children inflammatory bowel
disease center Stanford University
School of Medicine I'm Alexis Corrales
of labyrinth and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational webinar
presented by laberd's and sponsored by
ANOVA Diagnostics for more than 25 years
the ANOVA Diagnostics team has
collaborated with clinical researchers
to develop biomarkers to help advance
the care of autoimmune disease patients
they are redefining autoimmunity
leveraging their innovative spirit to
deliver solutions a tinted statement
means of laboratories and improve the
efficiency and quality of testing for
more information please visit
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation simply type them into the
ask a question box on the left side of
your screen and click on the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
now let's get started
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on this answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab and
follow the process to obtain your credit
additionally your slide window will also
automatically redirect you at the end of
the presentation where you can access
your credit I would like to now
introduce today's presenter dr. KP park
dr. Park is an associate professor in
the division of Gastroenterology
department of pediatrics and a Stanford
health policy faculty associate he
serves as the co-director of Stanford's
children IBD Center and the medical
director of the short-stay infusion unit
at Stanford Children's Health dr. parks
current NIH funded research is to
discover cost-effective ways to manage
Crohn's disease and ulcerative colitis
recently he is dedicated his clinical
practice and research endeavors to
monitor intestinal inflammation in
patients with IBS and IBD dr. Park you
may now begin your presentation
so much for that nice introduction and I
look forward to the conversation after
the presentation as well the title of my
talk is real-world utility of fecal
calprotectin testing and I really want
to emphasize the description here that
this is a real-world presentation from
my patients from patients that I treat
memorable cases that I think can help us
understand how the how the calprotectin
tests can be useful so here's my lecture
outline and I'll first talk about what
is calprotectin currently in this age of
biomarkers everybody's trying to find a
biomarker to monitor chronic conditions
and case one two and three really come
from my experience with this test over
the last six to seven years first is a
diagnostic case where I really started
to understand the potential for the
utility of calprotectin the second case
was this patient who had asymptomatic
disease he really did not have any
complaints and this was a way of
monitoring his condition without relying
on him reporting his disease activity
and the third is sort of a brief
snapshot of how we can use calprotectin
in a personalized way in this age of
personalized health and monitoring
self-monitoring of disease and finally
I'll just give a little discussion about
potential future utility so without
further ado what is calprotectin it's a
calcium bound protein extruded from
dying inflammatory cells particularly
neutrophils and monocytes they are
structural proteins so they're basically
the pillars
that hold up the cell wall and when you
think about how this particular protein
comes out of the cell and inserted into
the extracellular matrix when they have
died it can be a good marker of cellular
death and turnover there's some
pragmatic collection information that we
will discuss later on in the
presentation that's I think important
for education for the patient as they
are collecting their stool so this is a
book chapter that I recently helped
author with a with a senior fellow and
right away when we started to do the
research for stool biomarkers we
realized that calprotectin was just one
of many and here is just a list of some
of the more prominent biomarkers in the
stool that have been researched but
right now calprotectin is really the
leading commercially available biomarker
stool biomarker test for inflammation I
think we've had lactoferrin come on the
scene around the same time but really
calprotectin in terms of the patients
that I see with chronic inflammation in
the GI tract calprotectin has emerged as
the commercially available test of
choice and but I do want to comment that
we are looking and still trying to
discover what is the best biomarker it's
sort of like hunting for the Lost Ark
and I find that we're constantly
pressing the envelope to see whether
perhaps a constellation or
collective essay of these biomarkers
could be better than just looking at one
biomarker like the calprotectin so for
example we have a positive predictive
value and negative predictive value and
interestingly in the third line there
the neutrophil elastase that particular
biomarker could be a better predictor
for remission if you don't have any of
those in any of that or have very little
of that neutrophil elastase present in
your in your stool so there is a
possibility for other biomarkers to come
on the scene not just calprotectin but
right now I will focus on calprotectin
because that's what I use and that's
what I have most real-world experience
in so the backdrop of what I do is
treatment of patients with chronic
inflammatory bowel disease and these
conditions include Crohn's disease and
ulcerative colitis and this is a slide
from a recent paper that shows the the
epic increase in incidence of Crohn's
and all sort of colitis and if you know
anything about inflammatory bowel
diseases they can be quite debilitating
they can really impact the quality of
life essentially disable a person from
leading a normal lifestyle so previously
in the u.s. we thought maybe they're
gone 1.5 million or so patients with
inflammatory bowel disease but we're
really starting to realize that not only
is the incidence rapidly increasing over
the last decade or so but we're seeing
that maybe the actual total prevalence
is much higher than the 1.5 million and
this graph shows that even if we're
getting better at trying to diagnose the
disease
there's some signal there for sure that
the actual incidence is increasing in
developing and developed countries so I
want to move on to the first case let's
not get too far into the introduction I
want to really talk and spend time on
the real patients that help to take care
of and obviously these are just stopped
photos and they're not my real patients
and the names are the first names are
made up but they are real patients and
this particular patient I saw way back I
believe it was like 2009 or 2010 but
anyway she was a 16 year old adolescent
female who was quite accomplished she
was a cheerleader and was academically
high achieving and she had a couple
months of abdominal pain and occasional
diarrhea and we really thought this was
all related to stress and she had no
chronic medical conditions or problems
except for perhaps seasonal allergy she
really had no sick contacts or travel
she really had no risk factors and she
had a healthy diet and healthy lifestyle
and the pediatrician worked her up with
the appropriate complete blood count the
complete metabolic panel the celiac
panel stool cultures all of these were
negative but interestingly the
pediatrician checkup stool guaiac which
is a blood test to see if there's blood
in the stool and sure enough it was
positive and that's when they called me
just over the phone I hadn't seen her at
the time and I said interesting
let's get a cluster named difficile
toxin test and lo and behold it was
positive and we really thought this was
a community acquired Clostridium
difficile infection that
perhaps she got just in the community
and we treated appropriately and she
finished the course of oral flagyl or
metronidazole and reported improvement
but then three months later she comes
back to the pediatrician and reports on
you know early satiety occasional
diarrhea fatigue but the feat of testing
on repeat was actually negative and all
the other blood panels were normal but
interestingly her albumin was ever so
slightly low and you can get a low
albumin which is protein in the blood
just because you're not eating well or
you're malnourished so people thought
perhaps the diet was related to that low
albumin so my colleague ended up doing
an endoscopy colonoscopy and this was
completely normal everything looked good
except for just a little bit of stomach
irritation which i think is very
nonspecific so what happened there we
provided they were provided reassurance
um you know after a negative endoscopy
colonoscopy and they said that she had
irritable bowel syndrome and noticed
that there's a difference here irritable
bowel syndrome is different from
inflammatory bowel disease irritable
bowel syndrome is basically what a lot
of patients what a lot of people without
chronic conditions have which is just
they get upset stomach they get
occasional disordered stooling and they
need to check their dairy or their food
dietary history and sometimes there can
be a trigger and sometimes not so
irritable bowel syndrome is really not a
chronic condition that's disabling for
the most part so the patient then feels
frustrated and
decides to come to me as a new patient
for a second opinion and I thought to
myself this is a stressed-out teenager
who is high achieving and I'm sure there
is likely no path of pathology here but
reluctantly I ordered an mrn tro gram
which is an MRI to run the small bowel
and it was normal and everything so far
supported the diagnosis of irritable
bowel syndrome and because she just kept
on complaining I reluctantly repeated
another endoscopy colonoscopy and I send
out a stool calprotectin before that
scope and lo and behold this was one of
the first calprotectin as I had ever
sent and lo and behold it was 98
microgram program and I look up on the
internet and my papers in my archives
folder then noticed that hmm interesting
98 it seems to be slightly high and not
perfect so what do I do with that so
looking at the literature there seemed
to be this signal that if you had a
calprotectin greater than 50 microgram
program you really have a good
possibility of finding something on
endoscopy and colonoscopy so here's the
paper that I sort of went to and it was
the paper by Trimble this was one of the
landmark papers in gut which is a
high-impact journal and you can tell
that patients with Crohn's disease had a
clear increase in quantitative
calprotectin levels compared to patients
who had irritable bowel syndrome only
and patients who had other things other
conditions such as infections parasite
and cancer it could be sort of all over
the place as well but really I was
wondering whether this patient has
irritable bowel syndrome but this
patient had calprotectin close to 100
which really didn't sit with patients
with irritable bowel syndrome so I
repeat the endoscopy colonoscopy and lo
and behold I get into deep into the
small intestine where I think my
colleague previous did not get to and
there were offers on on the scope this
was the classic difficult to diagnose
duodenal crohn's disease and this is how
the you know my interest and and and and
evolution of calprotectin began so she
is currently actually still on this drug
called infliximab or Remicade and she's
doing really well she's in college now
and I think she might have even finished
college but anyway she's doing really
well
so that particular patient inspired me
to be be an academic for I question that
that I really just wanted to answer was
it cost-effective for me to send off a
sequel calprotectin test before I
started to go down the pathway of
endoscopy and colonoscopy so the first
left panel decision tree was we looked
at pediatric and adult patients who had
a fecal calprotectin test before their
endoscopy which was currently then not
the standard of care and tried to
compare that with just standard of care
which is no calprotectin testing and
going straight to endoscopy for a
patient who comes comes in with vague
complaints such as just I'm having
abdominal pain dear doctor please figure
out what's going on the second panel on
the right
is trying to get at the question of what
is the optimal cutoff do I consider
greater than fifty a indicator to go to
scope or should I consider greater than
100 because as you remember you know in
the patient's Stasi
she had a 98 so that was sort of right
there in the in between in between those
but closer to the the higher cutoff and
this was what was in the literature okay
so what did we find I won't bore you
with the details of the methods but
basically we found that it was actually
very cost-effective to go ahead and send
off a calprotectin before your endoscopy
colonoscopy as a gastroenterologist if
you were not confident that this patient
had Crohn's disease and ulcerative
colitis so essentially in a in adults
you would be saving for hundreds or four
hundred dollars or so per patient but
maybe you would have a little bit of a
delayed diagnosis among the 100 patients
that you encountered in clinic and then
in children you would save a little bit
less per patient and then maybe you
would have a little bit more patients
who might have a delayed diagnosis among
the hundred patients that you saw in
clinic now this is interesting because
in real life you don't want to lose
those patients to follow-up because
potentially they could have other
complications while not seeing their
doctor right so the reason why you save
a little bit less in the pediatric
population is because the pre D the
actual specificity is a little bit less
in the in children than in adults and
I'm not going to get into the
statistical meaning of of sensitivity
and specificity and why that impacts
cost-effectiveness analyses like what
I've done we've done here but clearly
the point take-home point is that in
pain
who come in with vague abdominal pain
and you're suspicious of irritable bowel
syndrome as opposed to inflammatory
bowel disease it is cost effective to go
ahead and test their stool for a
calprotectin and then in the second aim
we did note there in the fourth bullet
point there that calprotectin cutoff at
50 is actually more cost-effective than
at the 100 okay so moving along this
changed the way I practiced essentially
I I started to sort of tell all of my
gastroenterologist colleagues about this
because know I was oh I was really the
first one in my group anyway to start
sending calprotectin and it really
caught on and it really helped to I
think be more precise in the way we send
patients to an endoscopy and colonoscopy
which in Pediatrics obviously that's an
invasive procedure regardless of of
whether you have general anesthesia or
not and and the adults would would say
that it's invasive for them as well so
the point here is that I think this
really changed the way we looked at
calprotectin moving forward and we are
always trying to one we're trying as
clinicians we're trying to decipher
every moment how much value is the
patient reported symptoms so so a lot of
patients with irritable bowel syndrome
will come in and say I have abdominal
pain I have abdominal pain I have
abdominal pain and if you were to scope
them every single time they have
abdominal pain that's actually
malpractice and that would not be good
for the patient so that's over reliance
on the patient reported symptoms which
can lead to over medicalization and even
harm and increased healthcare services
when you have under reliance in
in the next case that I'm going to talk
to you about essentially the patient
might be stoic or they might not be
engaged in their health care and they
don't really report anything to you as
the clue as their doctor and this can
lead to the does lead to delayed
diagnosis a delayed prevention delayed a
comprehensive therapy plans so so I
think it's really important to
understand the precision that is
possible with calprotectin and not just
as a one-time decision tree maker of
whether you go to scope or not but we'll
talk about monitoring for the next
several slides here so I think it's safe
to say that patients are highly variable
variability is the law of life as as
William Osler said and not every each
patient is different and I think it's
safe to say that we have to consider an
objective marker such as calprotectin
which is quantifiable and with the
strength of evidence behind it to help
clinicians in their decision making and
recommendations for patients so I want
to move on to the case too because I
think this is where I now turn the
chapter again on calprotectin in the
real world and this is a real I really
enjoyed getting to know this patient he
is quite a funny guy he came to me as a
as an adult he was 20 and I'm sorry he
was he was then he came back to me as an
adult I initially diagnosed him with
ulcerative colitis at age 14 he was sort
of seen by other providers and
colleagues but anyway he initially
presented with just what we call moment
pan colitis meaning it presented with
really bad
and rectal bleeding and his entire colon
was affected he was hospitalised
initially and he required systemic
corticosteroids and biologic therapies
he even had to go on bowel rest and had
total parenteral nutrition and
interestingly this is the type of
patient that would have had their colon
removed in order to try to temporize the
disease but we we trialed a medical
therapy called tacrolimus which is used
in our transplant patients solid organ
transplant patients and it actually
worked and he actually got to keep his
colon and he always remembered that you
know that encounter of starting the
tacrolimus because it was a scary drug
at the time but interestingly this is
actually the most important point about
about Dylan he's always stoic he never
complained of pain he did not feel pain
I'm not sure if he had pain and just
didn't tell us or if his pain threshold
was you know in the stratosphere but
anyway he really was a stoic guy and he
meant and he might have had some
cramping but even with such a dramatic
presentation he was not complaining of
ongoing pain pain and pain so after he
got under control
he achieved really years of endoscopic
remission deep remission is what we call
it he successfully graduated high school
and then lo and behold he wanted to move
on to new and better things he had good
control over his all sort of colitis and
wanted to go to Puerto Rico with his
classmates after graduation and he said
he was in perfect health without any
symptoms of colitis and halfway through
that week in Puerto Rico he started
having rested waiting five to ten times
a day now mind you he did not have a
prodrome he was never in pain or had
these warning lights come on that would
tell him to tell me that he needs to be
seen in clinic before he went on to
Puerto Rico so returning home he was
dehydrated we barely got him in I think
in time and he had lots of blood loss
and was ultimately hospitalized again
for two to three weeks so the story is
quite dramatic but I think it shows you
the variability between patients and
ultimately we change his medications
around and we are monitoring his
calprotectin serial measurements
repeated measurements regardless of
symptoms so he can have no pain no
diarrhea and we're still going to check
his calprotectin
we are proactively monitoring him using
a non-invasive biomarker to track his
disease and he agrees that it's better
than getting a colonoscopy so there you
go so the you know I think I want to
zoom out just for this particular slide
and kind of show you all how
calprotectin fits into the paradigm of
how we monitor patients with
inflammatory bowel disease so clearly at
the top of the tip of the iceburg there
you have symptoms and then just
underneath that you have biomarkers or
blood in the stool
you can argue though I could argue back
that maybe imaging is not as good as
biomarkers and then you have endoscopy
just looking grossly at how the colon
looks when you go inside and and then at
the very bottom you have the histology
which is the gold standard we're always
aiming for end of
gothic or histologic healing okay
because like I said you can have lots of
pain and not a whole lot of endoscopic
or histologic disease or you can have no
pain and have a substantial amount of
endoscopic and histologic healing so I
think this is where the leveraging of
calprotectin monitoring can come in
handy which is what my patients do and
this is a paper that we just published
in inflammatory bowel disease which kind
of shows you in a schematic where how to
think about this so clearly when the
patient is not doing well it's in the
red and you achieve control through
therapy plan modulation immune
suppressant and trying to work with
different pharmacotherapy agents that
you have and the patient is clearly back
in the calprotectin target range there
are continuing to be monitored a long
time and then interestingly they will
have an inflection point upwards into
the yellow and you know at that
particular point that is the check
engine light that is where the car is
running well but there's something going
on that tells you you need to look a
little deeper and bring it back into a
good target range so we used to have
lots of debates about whether this was a
good use of resources but interestingly
there are papers now coming out that
that shows that this sort of proactive
monitoring and tweeting to target using
less invasive biomarkers is certainly a
a strategy that improves health outcomes
for our patients and this is the paper
recover
that that showcase showcases that
schematic
this was our this was actually the first
systematic review in patients with no
symptoms so we are certainly pushing the
envelope to how often and how how much
you should be relying on tell protecting
for your treatment strategies and I will
be the first one to say that the
systematic review that we published has
a weakness and the weakness is that
although we found a whole lot of studies
2,100 hits in in the database papers
when you filter out all the papers that
did not meet criteria for some reason
and they weren't you know robustly
designed we basically had only six
studies to to use in our quantitative
assessment so sorry our qualitative
assessment so so what we show is that
there is still a lot of research to be
done we have to keep pushing the
envelope to get better studies on
whether calprotectin does correspond to
and it's got the Keeling and I'll get
some more of what I mean by that but we
found that if calprotectin was elevated
times to to cereal testing you had up to
a 30 83 percent chance of developing a
disease Flair in the next two to three
months and if calprotectin was within
range or normal in the target range in
the green times - there's a
a very good probability up to 94%
probability that you will continue that
the patient will continue to be in
remission for the next two to three
months so we basically said in our
discussion of this paper that two
consecutive elevated calprotectin values
are highly associated with disease
relapse indicating that we need to think
about optimizing IBD therapy plans and
that more prospective data are needed to
assess whether fecal calprotectin
monitoring really improves health
outcomes and even as I was preparing for
this talk there have been some really
good papers coming into the into PubMed
showing that treating to target using a
using calprotectin is potentially
effective in improving health outcomes
for patients so what is this mucosal
healing why is it important why are we
thinking that we need to get to the
state of mucosal healing well literature
in the inflammatory bowel disease world
shows that when you achieve present-day
complete healing deep into the mucosa
deep remission you are potentially able
to bypass more aggressive future disease
so it's future modifying the disease for
the patient and I see that in in my
practice as I am taking care of patients
over years of of their early early
childhood into young adulthood that
patients who go into this deep remission
are more likely to stay in that deep
remission for a longer period of time
even if they get off of meds or change
medications for some reason and
eally disease activity indices such as
Crohn's disease activity in the index
the CBA I and the all sort of colitis
index these are these were helpful these
are still helpful but I think they are
falling a bit more out of favor and
perhaps we should we should be thinking
about calprotectin as a as an as an
objective biomarker to calibrate our
therapy plans so I wish we had a better
way of monitoring disease you I wish
there was a pill cam that just you know
take biopsies and I don't have to put
patients into uncomfortable anesthesia
or or or you know have the risk of
perforation or make them undergo a
clean-out but really this is the state
of affair with the picture of a
colonoscope here shows that we we are
still relying on the scope to monitor
disease and why is that important well
it's important as I said before patients
want a non-invasive approach to
monitoring so my third case is actually
[Music]
a boy who we'll call Cole and he came to
me from a rural area just south of
Oregon in north Northern California he
had very severe fiscal izing and
structuring type of small bowel crohn's
disease he was eight when he was
diagnosed he had an auto perforation
meeting his bowel
Bao ruptured and he had septic shock he
was very ill and he had multiple
abdominal surgeries and and small bowel
resections
and when you have a loss of bowel you're
not able to make as much calprotectin
as as someone who might have longer
length of bowel so for him calprotectin
was never that high it was not ever in
the 500 and a thousand it's always sort
of been you know under 150 but 150
monitoring and for the majority of my
patients would be would be fine I would
actually be okay with the 150 but his
calprotectin if it's over 100 it is
worrisome so this is where the
personalization of that quantitative
level the value can be important to
individualize the care delivered for
patients like Cole who has less bowel
for example and I think this is a
structural framework that I want to
showcase introducing this idea of
personalized health and monitoring using
calprotectin if personalized treatment
strategy is the goal you have at each of
the three corners here a personalized
way of thinking about the economics of
IBD not doing too much and not doing too
little right what tests are valuable we
are thinking about therapeutics does
this patient go on one biologic versus a
small molecule and then at the last
corner is that you know is that entity
that we're talking about in monitoring
how do we monitor non-invasively as much
as possible
in a personalized way and I don't think
in the near future colonoscopy and DA
Skippy will go away because as I said we
still need that histopathology that
histology is going to be the gold
standard but we do need to monitor more
frequently patients with the disease
without getting invasive so patients are
now some of my patients are now sort of
taking the liberty of sending me Excel
spreadsheets of their calprotectin
trends over time this is a patient who
love to work with Excel and he sent me
his nice run chart is what we call it
and you can see the green dots how
calprotectin was quite elevated when we
were trying to get him into deep
remission and he finally started a
treatment plan that worked for him and
he's in good remission as you can see in
this run chart clearly his top
perspectives have been persistently
under 100 which is great so going back
to that variability quote and and this
is where in the beginning of the
presentation I've talked about how there
are some pragmatic take home tips on
stool collection that I wanted to talk
about and I think it's important to kind
of standardize the collection as much as
possible and we can discuss this in the
Q&A because there's certainly a lot of
ways to think about this and how do we
educate patients on when is the best
time to collect given people's busy
schedules in the morning but
calprotectin in the morning is what I
recommend getting that stool sample in
the morning because there is up to a 26%
sorry a 23% variability depending on
whether you get it in the morning or at
night so I always say standardize your
calprotectin
sampling collected in the morning
because we certainly want to make sure
that we're comparing apples apples it
would basically be the same analogy of
using different scales to weigh yourself
when you know the scales haven't been
calibrated so I think that's one
potential education that we can improve
upon as clinicians so I want to talk a
little bit about three different things
very quickly that I think really
pertains to gastroenterologist and the
practicing clinician account number one
calprotectin predicts endoscopic
activity so you can see that the Mayo
score which is the score that we use
endoscopic scoring system to say whether
the patient has deep remission or not
you know Mayo score less than or equal
to one is deep remission and it predicts
really well calprotectin predicted
endoscopic remission in over 90% whether
you're using the standard Eliza or
whether you're using the point-of-care
test okay second calprotectin predicts
IBD relapse so in this particular study
again by Trimble and triple on we're
showing that that the predicted 50 / 50
microgram program predicted relapse with
90 percent sensitivity and 83 percent
specificity and interestingly this is
the paper in my mind that sort of raised
the point that these biochemical blood
markers to monitor disease that we've
been doing for
you know years may not be as good as the
calprotectin so the ESR and the CRP did
not significantly differ between relapse
and non relapse States but calprotectin
did so number three calprotectin
predicts grub responsiveness and this is
where when I when I start a patient on a
very expensive therapy plan like the
biological agents I will get repeated
measurements of calprotectin to see
whether they will ultimately respond or
not respond so calprotectin was able to
predict whether patients would be
responding to infliximab in this case at
at week ten
so I'm going to now close the talk it's
about wrapping this up by talking about
the future utility of calprotectin and
this is where we need to do more
research what is the accuracy of
calprotectin as a clinical endpoint for
endoscopic and histologic activity
according to different gastrointestinal
tracts so as you recall my some of my
patients had small bowel disease only
they their colon was not affected so in
patients who only have regional disease
there calprotectin should be different
their cutoff should be different than
patients who have their entire colon
affected right the same question what is
the correlation of calprotectin
monitoring with disease activity in
disease CRP and patient reported
outcomes so essentially we've been doing
the same thing for years monitoring
their CRP monitoring their their disease
activity and disease but really have we
done and
a true confirmatory test that showcases
that calprotectin may or may not may be
the only thing you need why are we doing
some of these other blood monitoring
tests and can we use the calprotectin to
fine tune and adjust and personalized
therapy plans before the check engine
light comes on before the overt sent
before the overt symptoms and and then
third question what is the comparative
effectiveness of calprotectin compared
to other biomarkers that we know exist
because we certainly want to not we
certainly don't want to settle on a
biomarker that is perhaps not as good as
other biomarkers or a collection of
biomarkers that we have yet to discover
and I want to showcase here just some
critical knowledge gap and research
priority that I think should be noted
and this research this international
consensus of experts called the stride
initiative concluded that there is a
major knowledge gap for fecal biomarkers
serving as endpoints of mucosal level
inflammation despite ongoing clinical
use we can be using this test for many
years to come but we still haven't
settled the question of whether or not
this can be used as a as a true endpoint
and I think here prospective studies are
needed to better understand this
question and interestingly a joint
consensus statement by folks from the
FDA and the European Medicines Agency
Health Canada and
pharmaceuticals and medical device
agency of Japan concluded that
accelerating the evidence to use
non-invasive biomarkers as reliable
surrogate endpoints is a top resource
priority in children affected with
inflammatory bowel disease because we
certainly cannot be undergoing general
anesthesia and having our kids affected
by this disease undergo repeated
measurements with colonoscopy so I think
the last slide here is just again the
the strength of evidence pyramid
showcases that we certainly can rely on
the surveys and the case control studies
and the even the cohort study but we
really need the randomized control
trials and the systematic reviews
remember our systematic review only had
six studies that met criteria for
inclusion so more research needs to be
done and I think the future of
calprotectin testing
has value as long as we understand that
there are knowledge gaps that we're
still needing to answer so with that I'm
out of time and I'd like to open it up
for questions
thank you so much for your time
Thank You dr. Park for your informative
presentation it is now time for our live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just type them into the ask a question
box on the left side of your screen and
click on the send button or answer as
many questions as we have time for if we
are unable to get to your questions dr.
Park will answer them via email
following the presentation so let's get
started
our first question is
you mentioned more studies needed for
mucosal healing education but what's
your experience been
well I just want to reiterate the fact
that new coastal healing has been going
back and forth for years now and the
definition of mucosal healing at least
for now
among clinicians seem to be endoscopic
or histologic evidence of no
inflammation and my experience has been
obviously tempered by the fact that I do
less invasive colonoscopies than say our
adult counterparts who do a lot more
endoscopic evaluations because they
don't have to put their patients under
general anesthesia but I think the
consensus overall is that that is the
optimal endpoint of choice we are all
among the IBD specialists aiming for
that that gold standard of endoscopic
and hopefully histologic absence of
inflammation so I just wanted to make
sure that that was clearly heard we are
aiming for endoscopic healing and
histologic healing but it is difficult
to get as I mentioned
our next question is my provider see the
value of calprotectin but I'm hearing
complaints on reimbursement are you
seeing the same issue
absolutely so I would say that there is
again variability between different
geographical areas where payers may be
different in terms of whether their
bylaws and their clinical guidance of
what can be reimbursed as they're going
as they're being updated so the payers
recognize that calprotectin is being
used but they're often seeing just the
diagnostic one-time screening
calprotectin test as something that is
more evidence-based than the monitoring
of patients with repeated calprotectin
measures now as we showed through our
systematic review there are plenty of
papers coming through the pipeline but
the robustness or the strength of
evidence for monitoring will need to be
prioritized so one of the major work
between the aga and the ATG and the
north american society of Pediatric
Gastroenterology particularly in our
society the Pediatric Gastroenterology
society we have resources for our
members the clinician members letters
and templates where we can go to the
appeals process and showcase the
emerging evidence and the value of
getting the calprotectin covered for the
monitoring piece so yes there is
variability yes I'm still seeing
calprotectin denied
but it is getting better every year as
the evidence gets better
our next question is for your experience
what is the sensitivity of the fecal
calprotectin tests for proximal youth
disease
that is a great question um I think when
the when the question is that what the
question is asking is I think what is
the sensitivity of upper trapped GI
disease meaning Crohn's disease limited
to the small intestine I think that's
what the question is asking and I would
say that it is unknown at this time
and my first patient in this case
presentation
I called her Staci she had upper track
Crohn's disease she did not have ileal
colonic or colonic Crohn's where you
would expect more of the quantitative
rise in the calprotectin but if you
notice that her calprotectin was still a
little bit elevated beyond what I was
comfortable with
so essentially
if you have visible lesion in the upper
intestinal tract in the duodenum jejunum
you're likely going to have
calprotectin levels greater than 50
micrograms per gram and that should be
your check engine light to evaluate
further for a real conclusive diagnosis
and if you're doing the calprotectin as
a screening or or continue to recognize
that there may be ongoing visible lesion
and a non you coastal healed state if
you're using calprotectin as a
monitoring test after the diagnosis so
what is the sensitivity for upper tract
crohn's disease I would say it depends
on the cutoff and if the cutoff is for
monitoring is 50 I would say it's still
very good possibly into the 90% but
again as I said this is needing further
validation with longitudinal studies in
that particular subgroup of patients as
I mentioned in the presentation
can our food habits cause any IBD
I'm sorry could you repeat that question
not a problem
can our food habits cause any IBD right
the food habits causing iv'e is is
arguably a Nobel prize-winning question
so I could literally spend hours on this
discussion and the foods we eat alter
and change our gut microbiota with each
and every meal the viruses that were
exposed to the fungus the microbial
ecology that that that is perpetually
around us will affect moment by moment
the ecology of the living microbiota
within our GI tract and we're
outnumbered by our gut bacteria ten to
one for human cells so clearly our the
foods we eat will feed our bacteria and
will be the fodder for lack of a better
term for this incredible jumble of gut
bacteria some gut bacteria are
pro-inflammatory some are
anti-inflammatory and protective of
inflammation but the gut bacteria serve
as a protective layer based on the the
secretions that they make such as mucus
such as such as short chain fatty acid
and when you have a very westernized
diet meaning low plant fibers yes you
are more prone for the literature
that we are more prone for a for
increasing interaction between the
environment and our and our the
immunology that goes on in our blood and
when that occurs that vulnerable state
called dysbiosis where our gut
microbiota are not diverse and and and
not abundant our immunity our immune
system may start to sample our GI tract
and somehow get confused that it's
actually something to seek and destroy
or target at least and cause a immune
response and that's really what and
Crohn's and all sort of colitis is it's
it's the self recognizing the epithelial
tract of your of your GI tract as
something to begin to attack the classic
autoimmune story so while the foods we
eat can alter the bacteria we certainly
require more research in the ideological
causes because diet is just one factor
and we haven't and we need to consider
that our that our environment is
changing everything around us is
continuing to evolve and I'll leave it
at that but I do know that among my
patients to have the diagnosis of
Crohn's and all sort of colitis when
their diet consists of more plant-based
foods and they start to think about
their Mike Carey their microbiota they
tend to have less inflammation overall
all right so our next question is
what specifically do you do to handle
denials for reimbursement
absolutely so number one when I get a
denial and I try to I try to send the
template letter that I have whether the
denial I rarely get denials for screen
as a screening test I am still getting a
few denials for monitoring IBD using
calprotectin so number one I have a
[Music]
ready to go letter with my top five to
seven literature papers showcasing the
clinical utility of
calprotectin monitoring and I send that
off to the payer and I am following up
with my office administrative team to
make sure that the payer received that
letter and it gets into the right and so
I think that's an I think that's a very
important follow through when you get
that denial you don't just send off a
letter you have to follow half somebody
has to follow through and make sure that
it was received and that it's being
reviewed at the second tier when I send
off the calprotectin
as a monitoring I make sure that the
diagnosis is correct it is Crohn's and
all sort of colitis but why am i sending
off a calprotectin I'm sending it off
because my patients are having symptoms
so I click that they're having diarrhea
bloody stools or abdominal pain etc and
I think that's the granularity that the
payers are
you're with not oh they have prawns
they're sending off calprotectin
I think it's got to be symptom based
indications so so make sure that that's
really indicated in my note and in the
end the clinic diagnosis codes and I
think thirdly if that doesn't work we
have to do a peer to peer and that's
where physicians have variability in how
aggressively we go to battle and I am in
the camp that count protected monitoring
improve the value of care so that's my
paradigm and the worldview that I come
that I am using calprotectin so I will
go as far as I need to go and call up
the medical director at the payer to
talk to them about the utility and ask
even to let me see your guidance on
calprotectin coverage and when that is
reviewed I often note that their last
literature rep refresh was from 2000 and
you know 14 so I kindly have a
bi-directional dialogue that you may
want to consider updating your your
guidance on internal guidance on what is
what should be covered sometimes they
just need to be reminded of the updated
literature and then I think lastly we
are all working at the national level
societies are providing resources and I
know from from my involvement and work
with the witne ask began the North
American Society of Pediatric
Gastroenterology hepatology and
nutrition that we have read
available resources and template letters
etc for our clinician members the
lengthy lengthy monologue there about
how to try to get it covered
so it looks like we have time for one
more question and just a reminder if we
didn't have time to get to your
questions they will be answered via
email following the presentation
would you clarify how often do you
request calprotectin in a recently
diagnosed patient before remission or
after remission
that's a tough question only because
every patient is different the variable
all variability but and what let's just
assume that the patient is starting
anti-tnf therapy you know one of the two
primary biologics that there are several
and TNF therapies but we usually go to
two we have two primary options so in
those situations I try to get a
calprotectin at baseline obviously
before therapy and then usually I try to
get one towards the end of induction
which is around one month to six weeks
and then I depending on how that patient
is doing I follow my systematic review
findings after I understand the
treatment response at the induction
phase of anti-tnf therapy I then monitor
every one to three months and I would
say that if you go past the third month
and they're a new diagnosis of
inflammatory bowel disease you may be
missing the opportunity to calibrate
your therapy and possibly optimize
treatment strategies to get them get
your patient to earlier deep remission
um since since clinical remission
doesn't always indicate mucosal healing
or deep remission as we discussed
so to summarize calprotectin a diagnosis
writer and then a repeat calprotectin
towards the end of induction
sometimes sometime between four to six
week mark and then depending on the
patient and how they're responding it's
every 1 to 3 months thereafter
thank you again dr. Park do you have any
final comments for our audience
I think the final take-home point is
that we need to continue to push the
literature we have to continue to think
outside the box on non-invasive
biomarkers continue to think outside of
just calprotectin we have to accelerate
the science of non-invasive biomarker
monitoring of disease and then we have
to use that literature to serve our
patients who would benefit from from
such a non-invasive more convenient way
of monitoring their disease
I would like to once again thank dr.
Katie Park for his presentation I'd also
like to see glabrous and ANOVA
diagnostics for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through July of 2018
you will receive an email from laborat
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye